the Senate Judiciary Committee's
chairman says Christine Blasi Ford must
decide by 10:00 a.m. Eastern tomorrow
morning
if she'll testify testify about her
sexual assault allegation against
Supreme Court nominee Brett Kavanaugh
Ford wants the FBI to investigate her
claim before testifying
now her lawyer last night accused Senate
Republicans of running quote not a fair
or good-faith investigation President
Trump told reporters yesterday he finds
the allegation in his words hard to
imagine Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill
talking to senators on both sides of
this simmering debate Nancy it seems to
be boiling over good morning to you it
sure is in fact I can tell you that that
letter from Ford's lawyers did not sway
Senate Republicans they say she can
testify in public she can testify in
private they'll even send staffers to
interview her in California but the one
thing they are not willing to do is
bring in the FBI
they say the Senate can investigate and
already is where I'm focused right now
is doing everything that we can to make
dr. Ford comfortable with coming before
our committee Judiciary Chairman Chuck
Grassley sent a letter to Democrats last
night outlining his plans for an
investigation committee aides he said
were reaching out to mark judge and two
other unnamed alleged witnesses
Democrats he added had thus far declined
to participate Republicans say the
committee is more than capable of doing
this investigation itself well are they
doing it nobody knows what they're doing
Democrats want the FBI to reopen
Cavanaugh's background check Cavanaugh
denies the allegations do you such an
outstanding man very hard for me to
imagine that anything happening
Republicans are weary of a
time-consuming unpredictable probe
wouldn't an FBI investigation shed light
on some of these I don't have enough
information to make that make that
decision the FBI investigated Anita
Hills sexual harassment allegations
against Clarence Thomas nearly 27 years
ago these FBI reports are extremely
important John Danforth who guided
justice thomas through the confirmation
process says an
dependent investigation is key to a fair
outcome the FBI has a responsibility to
conduct background investigations they
do it all the time more than a thousand
of Ford's fellow alumni have now signed
a letter to say they support her
Samantha Geary has known for since
middle school we have no doubt that this
was in fact her experience and I think
she's detailed it admirably in the
letter that she originally sent
Republicans say whatever Ford decides
they are moving ahead with their own
investigation they say aides interviewed
judge Cavanaugh under oath in private on
Monday and they appear Anthony to be
preparing to hold a vote in committee on
his confirmation next week I don't want
a drama I had Nancy Cordes thanks very
much Nancy